juste avant de jouer montre un truc
énorme voilà je vais vous montrer un
truc qui est exceptionnel voilà grâce à
quelqu'un autour de cette table il ya
une coupe qui a été fait
voilà je vous dis juste qu'est ce que
vous avez aujourd'hui parce que je vous
le dis il ya ça y est on va voir les
premières images de l'émission de strip
tease de tf1 parce qu'ils avaient la
conférence voilà qui était qui êtes vous
étiez bosnie comment ça va être cette
émission mais honnêtement c'est étonnant
c'est vrai ayalon tenant c'est détonnant
et alors j'avais une émission de strip
tease ckoi démission alors là non mais
s'il vous plaît
oui non c'est pas une émission de strip
tease c'était on l'était ce alors son
profit de la recherche contre le cancer
vous la sentez bien cette émission pas
moi je moi honnêtement oui je le sens
pas la chanter bear grylls et y aussi la
branche fret et canon je vous êtes une
fille regardez au regard d isabelle et
au la conférence de presse regarder
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un ami qui est à la conférence de
presse kapisa secret dans photo email
envoyé
voilà donc je vous dis au tessin vous
l'abordez du point on n'est pas on n'est
pas à l'école ici alors minute par
minute
j'en ai plusieurs des photos il ya une
fois la deuxième place est vrai que l'on
voit que vous regardez un truc là c'est
sûr vous êtes la seule sphère garder un
truc les yeux fermés comme castaldi a
grâce à isabelle je vous le dis il s'est
passé un truc exceptionnel vous le savez
isabelle la semaine dernière isabelle
nous a raconté quelque chose à semaine
dernière nous a raconté une anecdote sur
michel sardou ce que vous rappelez
oui très bien vous avez dit quoi sur
michel sardou j'ai dit qu'on était en
étant 87 en irlande avec l'équipe de
denisot et quand j'avais suivi michel
sardou pour vsd pendant plusieurs jours
il y avait plein de vedettes un pierre
perret renault shadow etienne daho tout
ça et que j'ai suivi pendant plusieurs
jours et que les pochtrons du coin comme
j'étais toujours à côté de michel sardou
pour leur portage les journalistes
locaux
il avait titré michel sardou et dans les
jambes et sa femme et sa femme isabelle
ce qui évidemment a été corrigé peu de
temps un peu de temps après et ça l'est
eh bien il ya le ici paris du 11 au 17
décembre donc le dernier qui est sorti
michel sardou son incroyable doublé mais
non avec les à cause de l'anecdote
d'isabelle et michel sardou fait la couv
le pauvre voilà le beau michel sardou
voilà regarder en irlande voilà sur le
plateau de cyril da comme l a précisé
sur le bateau les irlandais adoré cette
chanson beaucoup de photographes le
suivait et voilà et donc sa double vite
le chanteur a souvent eu le coeur
partagé entre deux histoires entre deux
femmes une fois encore impossible pour
lui de contrôler la situation
isabelle fout la merde merde